so we begin this newshour with breaking
news from nigeria and the united nations
says at least 110 civilians have been
killed and many more injured
in an attack in the northeast there have
been funerals for some of the dozens of
farmers
who were killed while working in rice
fields
local officials blame boko haram
fighters for
the violence and let's get the very
latest now from our religious who joins
us live from
the nigerian capital of abuja and ahmed
this is a truly dreadful attack
what more have you learned and why these
farmers were targeted indeed
shocking indeed nick we are hearing that
the attacks actually happened in two
villages
kosher bay
the funerals actually took place in
zabar marie what we're hearing now
is that 27 others have been
more than 27 others have been buried in
kosher bay hunt is now on for
maybe survivors but there are a lot of
people who believe that
dozens us dozens of bodies are still
there we've spoken with
a few officials there some of them
emergency workers who said
they are now on the search for more
bodies in that particular area
we are hearing also that at least 26
people have been taken away
the united nations also is confirming
that
many women have been abducted by the
attackers so it's a dreadful
event and of course one of the worst
massacres we've seen in recent years
after
what happened in baga some years back
so the nigerian government is
calling for calm and the president
issued a statement earlier today
condemning the attacks however what
people are saying
in that region is that the security
forces
and government have failed to protect
them and there is
little hope for them to see to it
that they have that peace of mind that
they require remember nick
a lot of people have traveled back home
or have gone back home they have left
refugee camps or internally displaced
persons camp in the safer areas of my
degree
to their homes in preparation for the
agriculture season earlier this year
and these people who are the ones
harvesting these crops
uh some of them were actually contracted
from far away places at sokoto
to come to my degree to help with farm
work and these are the people
that were buried today these kind of
attacks
i've made have been perhaps not on the
scale but they've been going on for more
than a decade why has the government
not been able to quell them
the government has claimed severally
that it has uh subdued boko haram or
it has claimed victory over boko haram
but what we've seen
in the last decade or so is a resilient
and resurgent boko haram
first of all it started in nigeria and
from
the city of my degree it's its
influence spread across border state
across 40 local government
areas of borno state in fact it reached
a point whereby
most of the local council council areas
in my degree were taken over by boko
haram the only safest place probably
would be the capital city itself because
it's a garrison town
it's protected by the military the
military you uh
make sure that the road linking my
degree to other parts of nigeria
one at least one road was kept open for
most of the
uh period boko haram was controlling
large space of territory
the military in collaboration with
regional forces have succeeded
in chasing out boko haram from such
areas but what we've seen is that boko
haram operates at will
and recently last year which was of
course the deadliest for security forces
we're talking about hundreds of security
forces killed by boko haram
and in order to reduce the casualty
numbers on the part of the military
they withdrew from certain villages and
smaller areas
to form some what they call super camps
forming those super camps exposed a lot
of villages
to attacks by boko haram and that's
what's been with what we've been seeing
for more than one and a half years now
and communities
sometimes communities cannot step two
kilometers outside of their villages
without getting
without getting or without being
attacked by boko haram
and these people these actors
usually or routinely drive on
motorcycles
and invade communities loot their
property kill and maim and abduct
as as they wish all right i'm going to
leave it there for the time being i
would address so reporting on that
dreadful attack there
by boko haram it seems reporting from
nigeria